the history of China suggests that China
is not inquisitive meaning they're not
going to go out and invade a whole bunch
of countries um now they do feel very
strongly you know so that's that's good
I mean because a lot of lot of very
powerful countries have been inquisitive
um the US is one of the also one of the
rare cases that has not been inquisitive
like after World War II the us could
have basically taken over the world and
any country like we got nukes nobody
else got nukes we don't even have to
lose soldiers is uh which country do you
want mhm and the United States could
have taken over everything oh at will
and it didn't um the United States
actually helped rebuild countries so it
helped rebuild Europe you it helped
rebuild Japan um this is very unusual
behavior almost
unprecedented
um you know the US did conspicuous acts
of kindness like the Berlin
airlift you know
um and and I think you know it's always
like well America's done bad things well
of course America's done bad things but
one needs to look at the the whole track
record um and and just
generally you know one one sort of test
would be how do you treat your prisoners
of War MH or let's
say
um you know no offense to the Russians
but let's say you're in Germany it's
1945 you got the Russian army coming one
side you got the French British and
American armies coming the other side
who would you like to be to surrender to
like no country is like morally perfect
but I recommend uh being a P with the
Americans that would be my choice very
strongly in the full menu of P very much
so and in fact Von Brown um yeah took
you know small guy uh was like we've got
to be captured by the Americans
yeah and uh in fact the SS was under
orders to execute B Brown and all of the
uh German rocket Engineers uh and they
narrowly escaped their SSI they said
they were going out for a walk in the
woods they left in the middle of winter
with no coats uh and then ran like and
with no food no coats no water and just
ran like hell uh and ran West um and by
Sher like they I think his brother found
like a a bicycle or something and um and
then just cycled where as fast as he
could and found found a US
Patrol um so anyway that's that's one
that's one way you can
tell morality is who who where do you
want to be a
PW it's not fun anywhere but some places
are much worse than others
so um anyway so so so like America has
been uh while far from perfect uh
generally a benevolent Force um and uh
we should always be self-critical and uh
we try to be better um but um anyone
with half a brain knows that so so I
think there are in this way China and uh
the United States are similar NE neither
country has been
acquisitive um in a significant way so
that's like a you know a shared
principle like guess um now now China
does feel very strongly about
Taiwan they've been very clear about
that for a long time um you know from
their standpoint it's it's it would be
like one of the states is is is you know
not there like like Hawaii or something
like that but but more significant than
Hawaii you know
um and Hawaii is pretty significant for
us so um they view it as as as really
the there's a fundamental part of
China the island of fosa not not Taiwan
that is um not part of China but should
be uh and the only reason it hasn't been
is because of the US Pacific
Fleet and as their economic power grows
and as their military power
grows the thing that they are clearly
saying uh is their interest will you
know clearly be materialized
yes China has been very clear that um
they will incorporate Taiwan uh
peacefully or um militarily but that
they will incorporate it from their
standpoint is 100%
likely you know something you said about
conspicuous acts of kindness as a
geopolitical policy it almost seems
naive but I'd venture to say that this
is probably the path forward how you
avoid most wars just as you say it it
sounds naive but it's kind of
brilliant if you believe in the goodness
of underlying most of human nature it
just seems like conspicuous acts of
kindness can uh reverberate through the
populace of the countries
involved yeah well and deescalate
absolutely so and in after World War I
the the they made a big mistake you know
they basically tried to lump all the
blame on Germany um and
um and and you know settled Germany with
uh impossible
reparations um and you know really there
was a lot of BL there was a fair quite a
bit of blame to um go around for World
War I um but they they try to you know
put it all in Germany
um and uh that was that that laid the
seeds for World War
II uh
so that's a lot of people well not just
Hitler a lot of people felt wronged um
and they wanted
Vengeance and they got it people don't
forget yeah you you kill
somebody's father mother son da
they're not going to forget it they will
want Vengeance um so after World War II
they're like well the treat of USI was a
huge mistake um in World War
I and um so this time instead
of
uh you know crushing the losers we're
we're actually going to help them with
the Marshall Plan and we're going to
help re reuil Germany we're going to
help reuil
or you know Austria and the other you
know Italy and whatnot
so
um that was the right move there's uh it
does feel like there's a profound
truth to uh conspicuous acts of kind as
being an antidote to
this something M up the the cycle of
reciprocal
violence something M stop it or it will
you know it'll it'll it'll never stop
just eye for an eye tooth for a tooth
limb for a limb life for a life forever
and
ever